montréal a accueilli cette semaine le
46ème congrès internationale
d'apiculture un événement rassemblant
près de 6000 participants de 137 pays au
coeur des discussions le déclin
important des pollinisateurs
on en parle de tout avec valérie
fournier professeur au centre de
recherche et d'innovation sur les
végétaux de l'université laval
on y retrouve bien sûr à québec bonsoir
bonsoir alors parlons des abeilles
on en compte combien dans le monde et
comment vont-elles oui alors bien sûr il
ya l'abeille domestique que tout le
monde connaît s'agit d'une espèce la
piste mellifera puis bien sûr tout plein
d'abeilles sauvages se sont un peu moins
connus au canada ça compte ces 900
espèces différentes d'abeilles sauvages
qu'on à travers le monde ces vingt mille
espèces d'abeilles sauvages donc espèces
sauvages et espèces domestiques deux
choses différentes qu'on voit à l'écran
ce sont des des espèces sauvages mais
quand elles sont dans des ruches avec
les les panneaux qui hantent ce sont des
espèces domestiques sont l'abeille
domestique ouais c'est l'abeille
domestique
une abeille introduites lot d'europe qui
produit du miel les espèces sauvages ne
produisent pas niel alors le on parle
souvent de déclin est ce que c'est un
déclic poursuit paix pour les abeilles
sauvages
oui absolument on parle à l'échelle de
l'amérique du nord c'est environ 25% des
abeilles sauvages l'option en danger en
péril ou en fait disparu certaines comme
baume de sa fille nice qui est un
bourdon qu'on n'a pas vue depuis une
dizaine d'années alors qu'il était très
abondant avant us que plusieurs espèces
en danger cause autrement oui ben c'est
ça dont 25% je voudrais de 900 espèces
look sont en danger
donc ça fait quand même le beaucoup
d'espèces
alors quelles sont les solutions que
sont les solutions qui sont proposées
pour améliorer l'état des choses la
santé des abeilles si on peut dire oui
alors une solution dans ces 2
de planter plus de fleurs en fait les
ressources florales c'est la nourriture
des abeilles donc diluer la les
pesticides avoir des pratiques agricoles
également qu'ils sont plus plus
environnementale donc moins d'herbicides
par exemple on veut aussi préserver les
habitats les habitats non défricher donc
on des habitats naturels en milieu
agricole ça prendrait les recherches
démontrent que ça prendrait 20% au moins
minimum d'habitats naturels ou semi
naturels pour préserver la santé des
abeilles sauvages
donc ce sont des solutions importante
est ce qu est ce qu elles sont
appliquées ces solutions là où le déclin
ne fait que grandir
ouais bon ça dépend des régions le
voudrait si je prends l'exemple du
québec là que je connais un peu mieux
évidemment où québec la montérégie par
exemple c'est une région là où il ya
beaucoup d'agriculture assez intensive
on parle de soya maïs est environ
seulement 7% d'habitat naturel dans le
paysage en montérégie
si on prend l'exemple harris de l'esprit
l'on est à environ 35%
donc cessons donc pour avoir par exemple
montérégie où on augmenterait le
pourcentage d'habitats naturels
c'est certain que ça aurait des
conséquences économiques parce que le
maïs et le soya c'est des cultures qui
rapporte énormément d'argent
l'uma et si on parle des abeilles en
retour que les la contribution des
abeilles à l'économie elle est assez
énorme en fait ya 87 % de nos cultures
en agriculture le qui sont dépendants
dépendant des pollinisateurs pour faire
les rendements donc rapidement l'oeil
pommier bleuets
canneberge mais en fait tous les légumes
qu'on consomme produire la semence de
ces légumes la recadre les
pollinisateurs
donc c'est majeur oui c'est absolument
majeur les citrouilles le melon etc etc
ah ouais l'épopée pardon le café aussi
même si on a on n'en fait pas pousser au
canada le café mais le cas fine qu'une
plante on boit du café tout le monde les
adultes est une plante qui requiert le
service des pollinisateurs les
populations d'abeilles sauvages donc
sont en déclin mais en même temps les
colonies des apiculteurs sont en
croissance
est ce que c'est une bonne chose quand
même ça oui quand même c'est une bonne
chose mais en fait il faut mettre en
perspective que s'accroît mais en même
temps les les apiculteurs doivent
travailler vraiment fort parce que eux
aussi subissent des pertes important dû
à la aux pesticides par exemple ou
pertes hivernales donc les apiculteurs
doit vraiment redoubler d'efforts pour
compenser leurs pertes et en redoublant
d'efforts elle
elles font en fait que elles peuvent
produire le plus de colonies parce que
les services de pollinisation sont en
forte demande en forte croissance donc
les apiculteurs se doivent de de faire
plus de colonies l'apiculture urbaine et
populaire multiplication des ruches en
ville sur les toits notamment est-ce que
ça c'est une bonne chose
c'est une bonne chose dans une certaine
mesure oui ça permet de faire la
sensibilisation de l'éducation en milieu
urbain maintenant si on a trop de ruches
en milieu urbain c'est que et on rajoute
pas de fleurs en parallèle donc on
n'ajoute pas de ressources florales
c'est qu'on va saturer l'environnement
et puis il y aura tout simplement plus
de nourriture pour non seulement
l'abeille domestique on a introduit en
ville mais les pollinisateurs sauvages
qui sont l'autre façon naturelle
donc s'il ya un petit ange ici
l'apiculture urbaine effet en ajoutant
pas de ressources florales ya un danger
à plus ou moins court terme quelles sont
les innovations il y avait ce congrès de
l'apiculture cette semaine quelles sont
les innovations qui ont été présentées
ou que vous retenez particulièrement
oui en fait ce congrès l'oeil à un gros
volet scientifique auquel j'ai participé
et aussi un volet exposants apicole donc
beaucoup d'exposants y en avait plus de
200 de ce côté-là eu la grosse
innovation ce qui va tirer vraiment les
foules d'apiculteur c'est une machine
une création québécoise une machine pour
produire du miel crémeux avec fruits
donc ça c'est un marché qui se développe
beaucoup c'est du miel mais crémeux et
on rajoute des fruits comme bleuets
canneberge des petits fruits le bien
souvent donc ça c'est très populaire
c'est en vol depuis ça marche il qui
grossit donc cette machine est une
machine environ 30000 dollars
puis elle le fait le führer donc voilà
prêts intéressants merci beaucoup
valérie fournier pour ses explications
ce soir merci merci à la prochaine au
roi